je parle pauvre chien que je parle Greta
je parle pour mic match
que vous incarnez pour moi l'artiste
libre je vous donne vous avez travaillé
6 ans sur votre nouveau livre disque
maudit silence et j'ai un peu
l'impression que c'est l'oeuvre de votre
vie vous avez raison en ce sens que
c'est la synthèse de toute ma vie de
tout ce que j'ai fait de tout ce que
j'ai dit chanter
crier c'est c'est ça je voulais faire
une sorte de parcours résumé synthèse
puis c'est vrai ce que vous dites soyez
un discours la force de Maud silence
c'est que c'est un livre disque qui nous
fait voyager vous chantez en innoie
haïtien en portugais et vous même vous
avez voyagé beaucoup pour mon Disneyland
beaucoup beaucoup mais j'ai voyagé
beaucoup puis ça c'est toutes les
langues au fond latine créole qui font
partie de ma langue latine alors oui
puis mes voyages j'ai d'abord été à
Haïti en 2015 avec Joséphine bacon dans
les nuits amérindiennes mais j'ai fait
un voyage avec jean-maurisset on est
parti en Patagonie quand j'entends Lola
qui est déjà qui chante et qui dit c'est
poème sur l'album on l'entend et ben je
suis allé là où ils étaient les patagons
c'est vraiment
puissant comme ce qu'on
ressentez Enez nous mais en 2009 vous
aviez aussi réalisé un album
complètement en inou avec Joséphine
bacon et c'est elle qui vous a appris à
parler la langue en quelque sorte
tu ne connais pas mon histoire je
collabore avec Joséphine bacon au fond
je l'ai connu en 1982 ou même moment que
j'ai connu j'ai le car les Gaston
mirront alors ça fait tout un tipi à
trois branches puis je vous ai fait
finalement
on s'est développé comme une sorte de
d'amitié
comme comme deux sœurs qui calme elle
m'a donné elle m'a pris par la main
matin
[Musique]
justement vous êtes de descendance
métisse d'où vous avez vu cette passion
pour la culture autochtone mon ancêtre
est arrivé en 556
il est allé comme on disait à l'époque
évangéliser les sauvages
fait que moi avec le père le mois puis
j'ai ça dans le sang je veux dire mes
ancêtres moi c'est pareil je dis c'est
la même ligne du côté de ma mère les
laramis le fort la rami ou ce qu'on sait
c'est dans ma lignée aussi donc les
courroyeurs des bois sergent fait partie
ALGON qui est
[Musique]
un retour en arrière le premier livre
que vous avez lu c'est la Bible parce
que vous venez d'une famille assez
croyante de Saint-Eugène ça c'est dans
le coin de Drummondville dans les terres
plates
donc à quel moment vous êtes passé de la
religion à la vie d'artiste
pour moi c'est la même chose c'est
il y a un journaliste qui disait je
pense c'est jambes au noyer les artistes
et les derniers croyants et je peux vous
dire que c'est vrai parce que pour être
artiste il faut y croire tu vis tu
regardes les poètes aussi qui vivent
souvent
dans la DH peu d'argent faut enseigner
pour pouvoir organiser sa vie comme
poète
[Musique]
vous ouvrez la porte justement parce que
pour votre disque d'avant à la croisée
des silences semble-t-il que vous vous
êtes endetté de plus de 100000 dollars
j'ai comme l'impression que vous êtes
allergique à l'argent que vous êtes mal
je suis allergique à l'argent parce que
j'ai accepté de mourir pauvre c'est une
clé importante qui peut avoir l'air
comme une boutade mais c'est pas une
boutade c'est quand on prend la décision
et qu'on accepte de dire j'accepte de
mourir pauvre ça change toute notre
vision des choses tout tout tout et là
on devient libre puis on prend des
décisions dans une liberté totale Robert
Robert où est ton arbre vous êtes la
gardienne de la mémoire de votre
conjoint j'ai le cadre qui nous a quitté
il y a près de 13 ans comment vous
habitez encore aujourd'hui il m'habite
tous les jours je l'engueule tous les
jours je lui parle tous les jours
pleure avec lui je lui dis aide-moi dans
quoi je me suis embarquée encore je vous
jure je n'ai pas coupé la communication
avec j'ai le cas je lui parle et je vais
toujours lui parlerai et il me répond
tout Sainte Marie merci beaucoup pour
cette entretien et j'ai bien de vous
retrouver ici au théâtre autrement pour
votre rentrée Montréal merci merci
beaucoup